who taught you who sat you was there
someone that sat you down and was like
like did you have a mentor that was like
hey you know this is how you no i don't
know i don't know if i had a mentor i
just i was always like my brokest friend
so i was like always that dude willing
to do anything for five bucks
rich guy you just taught yourself how to
do it i i once i started to make money i
never had money but once i started to
make money i mean i called it a blessing
call it a blessing in disguise
i started my first year of business that
i actually started like in this same
business financial sales i made five
grand one year people were like how's
that even possible i was crashing on
couches i was investing my time i knew
that if i started a deal would take
three to six months to even get funded
it was an investment in myself first
year five five grand second year i made
a hundred grand sick
talking the most i ever made in my life
in my early twenties was 25 grand before
that okay now i get 100 grand what am i
gonna do with this [ __ ] right now
boom financial meltdown 2008. ah
okay
you had it we used to do business with
uh lehman brothers
we had funding from bear stearns out of
business gone people that we had set up
fund relationships with done we got no
funding credit squeeze gone by
my my uh my mentor my business partner
now is my business partner he was
driving a sick mercedes trades it in for
an audi he's like i can't afford this
[ __ ] anymore
companies get laid off
if you don't learn from that you ain't
going to learn from nothing
so i realized that you know 27 years old
i made 100 grand 28 almost and i'm like
yeah i'm going to save this yeah i'm
going to save this
um and then when i started to make more
money and more money and i'm attending
meetings and networking and i'm in this
in this world of financial advisors and
wealth planners and estate planners
something that i've always done is ask
questions i've always been very curious
hey well let me ask you about this hey
about that let me ask you like i'm on
the pbd podcast yeah
i'm not the most
opinionated person on the podcast
i'm the person asking a lot of questions
hey danielle you're an economist let me
ask you why this is a big deal about
this uh evergrande situation in china
never heard of them quite frankly but is
this gonna affect us here in america
could you answer that hey biz doc you've
had an exit where you've made a couple
million dollars you you know has built a
billion dollar brand can i ask you a
question hey pbd you've built a massive
insurance company you've built a massive
media company can i ask you a question
two ears for a reason over here one
stupid mouth and i'm in the middle of my
face bingo anyway so that was always my
thing i was able to ask people and
that's how i started my show sucks money
i didn't say i didn't start saying this
is what you need to know about money i
have all the answers the hell do i know
yeah 30 something years old i just
started making money what the hell do i
know what i started doing was asking
every single financial advisor the same
question if you give one piece of advice
to millennials what's the one piece of
advice you would ask
right and then they would answer it
eight out of ten say save that money
yeah eight out of ten there are
obviously people that starts with a
budget you gotta invest index funds this
is pre-crypto
but save that goddamn money yeah and i
just and i opened my eyes
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken
[Music]